les portes de ces jardins sont ouvertes
depuis le 27 mars dernier le domaine de
dampierre en yvelines propose aux
visiteurs de flâner dans ses allées et
de découvrir toute la végétation de ce
site
ce sont des jardins patrimoniaux puisque
évidemment autour du château qui est en
chantier
nous avons les jardins qui sont les
vestiges jardins de le nôtre et les
jardins à l'anglais zh nous avons 90
hectares de jardin où le public peut se
balader en plein air pour la saison
printanière 25000 bulbes de tulipes et
de jongh qui ont été plantés par les
jardiniers cet hiver pour égayer ce
confinement et c'est le printemps et
donc au gré des jours et des saisons des
mois et bien nous avons jusqu'au à peu
près jusqu'au 15 mai une floraison
constante de ses bulbes pour fêter le
printemps
les visiteurs peuvent également monter
dans une calèche pour découvrir ce
domaine du xviie siècle pendant une
heure pour continuer à proposer cette
activité des règles sanitaires ont été
mises en place
on désinfecte systématiquement
avant chaque départ le public se
désinfecter les mains aussi mais on a
maintenu cette activité attelage parce
que les murs elles ont besoin de
travailler et donc il faut les entraîner
il faut faire venir le public aussi pour
que voilà de faire partager ce moment
exceptionnel parce qu'on traverse la
forêt avec ses animaux et ses paysages
extraordinaires et donc du coup on
limite à 12 personnes par attelage pour
visiter l'intégralité du site il
faudrait y passer la journée le plein
tarif est à 8 euros